it's been over three months since i made  my last high-end imac leaks video and  while i'm still firm on some of my  predictions like there being no way that  the display size will go up to 32 inches  as well as being 100 sure about the chin  sticking around  i do want to admit that i've completely  changed my mind on a very important  aspect of the imac the performance apple  is much more likely to give us a 20 core  m1 max duo chip option by literally  combining two m1 max dies into one  package i expected to scale really well  compared to the regular m1 max with only  up to around 10 percent efficiency loss  due to the infinity fabric connection  between dies it's going to have black  bezels for sure as well as coming in a  space gray color and as far as the  release date it needs to happen at an  official apple event this points at an  apple march event reveal